das unternehmen beschäftige und service
einer virtual reality 3
ungewohnte thorium früher sogar einen
peinlichen territorium
wichtig bei und max kühner trifft sich
alle hinter ihm das kleine wohnzimmer
wird heute noch übertreffen ist mir
bringt manche auch bett und dann hört
man die alten platziert und wieder als
team verfügt und bei änderungen kanada
die mit ihnen spielen lesen kann fordert
die linke eine 2000 jahre später wird
mit gedrosselter egal wohin schaut das
impressum gehört also ich sehe gerade
quasi neben mir in welche bild
schwierigkeit der hand hier irgendwie
herr greifen ich kein alter
[Musik]
durch den bürgern dann werden wir
schauen vorne schieben
früher sagen hier einstellen
ein bisschen wehmut schwang papier
gedruckt wir werden jetzt sicherlich
[Musik]
errichtet wir haben hier noch ein
schmetterling der antrag auch hier eine
rache und wir haben noch eine pistole
treiber dafür nur noch galerie
katholisch wetter lieber vor recht
unterschiedliche die kleider risiko jahr
einstecken musste
eine andere art und warum stückchen
agenten und jetzt mal schauen beginnen
kann ich mich normalerweise eher weniger
eine million ganzen bildschirm immer
noch aktive angepeilt
ich hatte jetzt mal eben ein bisschen
diese gegenstände bürger dazu treffen
ich habe hier meine damen und herren ich
weiß dass ich überhaupt in die partie
nehmen die hier unsere einschieben
wir schauen aber fertig werden kann dass
wir freunde rolle als wert von 4
einwürfe und optischen wirkung meine
langen haare kommen verschiedene wege
wie wir sind jeweils schmetterlinge
einer hand was ihr deswegen wir glaube
ich kann auch stehen bleiben aber
irgendwie sind gerade alle
aber die abhilfe kommt die
schwerelosigkeit ist es auch gewerblich
wird auch gelebt aber entspannt wie er
künftig auch gleich sein lassen die er
sich bei 50.000 leiterin machen dich
noch mal irgendwann vielleicht noch aus
wie verdi skeptisch diese komischen wie
die schmetterlinge auf wenige skoda
gekommen dass die waren die akten
bekommen hat darüber hinaus drückten
hier keine kriege aufgezeichnet werden
dass irgendein kleine knöpfe hierbei den
bildschirm kann ich nicht machen das
kann hier die frage
hier oben haben wir auch jetzt keine
knöpfe ich würde sagen und hänge die
auch durch nochmal ganz auf das den
roten knopf 2000 jahre später irgendwann
geschieht hier gerade davor sich
irgendwann auch keine ahnung was
passiert hier brauche ich weiß nicht
ganz genau wir gerade vor dem
wahrscheinlich beenden
[Musik]
dpa alle brauchen irgendwie auf und ab
freunde ich habe jetzt die oftmals die
ganze dass ich in die richtung brücke
aber er braucht jedenfalls kranke
erfahrungen gerade auf jeden fall machen
auch ein video online gegangen wo wir
ein spiel gespielt haben wo wir auf
jeden fall auch klaus abonniert bekannte
die ihr werdet auch eingeladen und damit
dieses geld